Scandals
that's what connects us
to so many scandals.
The king of scandals,
President Donald Trump.
Just for a moment,
can we just all acknowledge
can we just all be honest
and just say that
the Trump address
didn't hit like
we thought it was going to hit l
Don't be sensitized to scandals
now that Trump addressed
it didn't do what I thought
it was going to do.
The Trump
arrest was like a pat brownie
you ate 4 hours ago.
You have I feel justice.
This go feel like justice.
Let me travel to Georgia.
Arraignment.
Brown is made without a hit
on the dozens that's got some ki
taint follow trump scandals.
There's too many Trump scandals
to keep up with.
Keeping up with Trump scandals
is like watching Star Wars movie
You got to watch the third one
to understand the first one.
Then you got to
you can't miss the second one
because it's got Easter eggs
for the fifth one.
Donald Trump is the only politic
who scandals got spinoffs on Dis
but the Trump arrests,
it made everybody question
what they believe
You thought you lean one way pol
then Trump that locked up.
Everybody started waffling.
Put Republicans
between a rock and a hard place.
Donald Trump that locked up for
All Republican.
I've been saying for years
we got to get tough on crime.
Trump got arrested.
We met black crime
Same thing with the liberals.
Two liberals was all confused
after Trump got arrested.
We got to abolish prison.
Trump got arrested, bring back r
I don't know about you all, but
the easiest scandal to follow
was the Trump document scandal.
That was the one that was easy t
Simple is some stuff
it is supposed to be in the Whit
That ain't
in the media.
Y'all did your job.
Donald jumped on that story.
As soon as the Trump documents
story broke.
Everybody was down at Mar
a Lago
who is reporting live
from the documents Tottenham.
And then we found out
Joe Biden had documents, too.
And it was like, it's not a big
It's not a big deal.
Everybody got documents.
Everybody got back.
When Mike Pence has some back
out of the oh, look,
the tiny spy balloon.
Would you look at that?
Oh,
well done, media.
Happy to be here.
Very happy to be here.
If there's one person
that could use the scandal,
it's Ron DeSantis.
That boy is just running around,
just passing every controversial
he can think of.
Thinking Mexico activate bonus.
That's not how you activate vote
in this country, Ron.
Everybody know how you do politi
This is America.
We don't pass laws.
You make a promise to voters,
and then you don't do it.
That's what
the great leaders
in this room understand.
You know how to make things not
The only thing the only thing Ro
DeSantis has done
that I got to give him credit fo
this boy that got people riled u
all the stuff they can understan
Don't nobody.
They don't know what
critical race theory is.
Get these people riled up about
that they can't even define, lik
or NFT.
Ask any Republican,
this anti CRT,
any Republican trying to explain
They sound like a Democrat tryin
to explain the charges against T
It's bad everywhere.
I've got to stop it.
We've got to stop it. We got the
We got files.
We'll be right back.
I'm Rachel Maddow. I have files
rachel maddow.
Get them files on.
Yes, a wrap
i think Republicans
would be surprised, man,
if y'all just be real
about what CRT is that?
You can be surprised.
Some black folks
might might meet you halfway,
but you got to tell the truth, y
A lot of black people call it wh
And talk
CRT policies are an attack
on black history
and an attempt to erase the cont
of black people from the history
That's what it is.
You are trying to erase black pe
and a lot of black people wouldn
mind some of that erasure
as long as that
black person is Clarence Thomas.
A
billionaire named Harlan Crow,
flying Clarence Thomas.
All over the world
on unreported trips
like the Instagram model, taking
to the
Maldives and the beaches
and all Paperless Mama's house.
This billion
to pay for Clarence Thomas, this
I got to give it up
to billionaires, billionaires.
Boy, y'all, y'all are relentless
Yo,
y'all always come up
with something new to back.
Like, just when you think of eve
you could buy on Earth,
the billionaires will come up
with a new thing.
Ya'll about space rockets.
You bought Twitter.
This man bought a Supreme Court
do you understand how rich you h
to buy a supreme a black one?
On top of that,
there's only two in stock
and Hartland Pro owns
half the inventory
we can all see Clarence Thomas,
but he belongs to billionaire
Harlan Crow.
And that's what an NFT is
Everybody's got some scandal stu
Despite the challenging times we
in, I look around this room
and I see people that are hardwo
Many of you.
I don't even think
you should be working that hard.
We should be inspired
by the events in France.
They rioted
when the retirement age went up
to 64.
They rioted
because they didn't want to work
Meanwhile, in America,
we have an 80 year old man
begging us for four more years o
begging,
begging
let me finish the job.
That's not a campaign slogan.
That's a plea
limitation, no definition
I do.
I do wish you the best of luck
on the campaign trail, Mr.
President.
You got a lot of things
that you're going to have to nav
a lot of hurdles.
You've had quite a few scandals.
You know, we
I know we know about the documen
We know about the laptops,
but there's been no scandal
more damaging than the scandal.
Love Is Joe Biden awake?
Say what you want about our pres
Look,
when he wake up from that
nap, work gets done.
He might doze off with the infra
bill.
O student loan forgiveness.
Hey, do we free
Brittney Griner, free Brittney G
but I think the most insulting s
to fall
to the feet of the Biden adminis
was place at the feet of our mad
vice president.
The scandal of
what does Camilla do
which is a disrespectful questio
That's a disrespectful question
because nobody ever asked
that question
of the vice president
until a woman got the job
I'm going to ask
I don't know what Mike this be.
The only thing I know about Mike
is that he's really good at play
and seek at the Capitol
you've got to be crafty
to catch Mike Pence in that capi
heating the wall of nooks and cr
Don't put the camera on her
and the Mike Pence joke.
Don't do that.
Well,
he said he's trying to set you u
Madam Vice President,
at the end of the day,
as a vice president,
the only thing
only you got to do
is just be better than Dick Chen
Gets the ball.
Just be better than Dick Cheney.
They made a documentary about Di
Cheney.
Now, I don't know
much about the job of vice presi
but I do know if they can make
a documentary
about your time as vice presiden
you vice president.
It incorrectly
and if a VP VP's job is really
just waiting
to step in to save the country
in case of emergency,
then the job of vice president
is a perfect job for a black wom
Shouldn't be, but it is.
And whatever you do accomplish,
whatever you do accomplish,
are you going to do it?
Just give a man credit for anyth
you do.
All the immigration stuff
you were knocked out,
didn't got all this banking,
and you got the internet down th
You're taking care
of all this postpartum stuff.
They just going to give a man cr
for what you done, by the way.
Mr.
President, great job
at being the first woman vice pr
of color.
I don't even know how you did th
Wonderful job.
Happy to be here.
But tonight
tonight is all about you,
all the journalists,
the defenders of free speech,
the people who show truth to the
through different mediums,
through television,
through print, through radio,
through whatever.
Trying to let us see you on Twit
but the industry
that covers all of these scandal
isn't immune to them.
They're self
the issue with the media is that
most people can't afford that.
All the essential, fair
and nuanced reporting,
it's all stuck behind a paywall.
People can't afford rent.
People can't afford food,
not healthy food.
They can't afford an education.
They damn sure
can't afford to pay for the trut
Same as you one
about a conspiracy theory, but
at least is affordable
listening.
Alex Jones.
It cost you about not having to
and I understand that
we have to put this stuff
behind the paywall
because creating the truth is im
People can't afford the truth,
but you all can afford
to go find the truth.
For free.
The work you do as
journalists is important.
It's essential.
It's dangerous.
My father was an embedded
reporter on the frontlines
with black platoons in Vietnam.
He was in the South African Sowe
He covered that
the civil war in Rhodesia,
which we know today is Zimbabwe.
And my father came back
home and co-founded
the National Black Network
because he wanted to tell black
to American Urban
Radio Networks now,
and they've been doing it for 50
And that's part of what my fathe
wanted to do. You know,
and I know it was hard because,
know, black
dad is loved
telling you when something was d
They were shooting at me.
Boy, I
but I never dropped my tape reco
my daddy tell war stories
like Brian Williams
Lester Holt didn't laugh at that
Okay. So I don't know
good journalism, cos
that's the truth of the matter.
The journalism cost the people,
but it also cost the journalists
It could even cost you your free
We talked about,
even though The Wall Street Jour
sitting in a Russian prison
as we speak on espionage charges
which espionage charges, by the
that's the foreign equivalent
of saying someone fits the descr
Evan.
And hundreds of journalists
imprisoned all over the world
simply for doing their job.
We got to defend brave journalis
Most national stories in this co
at some point were first a local
and
those stories are
championed by reporters at outle
that many of them have now folde
If we can't figure out a way
to pay local reporters,
then as a country
we're only left
with that many more blind spots
to where the ball is happening.
You hear about all these newsroo
getting cuts.
I see every article that Tamra's
been sending me in
the last two months is just
the newsroom is getting cut,
cutting people with cutting budg
But you never hear about the mul
dollar executives
reducing their salaries
within these organizations.
Now, how do we fix this
I don't know.
I'm a comedian.
I was just up in
It's not my job to have the solu
that's only.
But local local reporting
is very important.
My mother is here tonight
and
I know she's furious right now
because I'm trying to put on cam
But my mother was among
a group of black student protest
fighting for equality in the six
At Delta State University and
and
that was a dangerous time.
But those types of incidents
were covered by local reporters.
And some of the shame
that came
from the national embarrassment
of treating people inhumanely.
It's part of the pressure
that helped to create
that type of change.
What would have become of my mot
and those of the protesters
of the local journalists
wasn't there telling the story
and now is no different.
But thankfully,
my mother's story was told
she got to complete a degree
at Delta State
and continued on to Florida
A&M and got another degree.
And then for the last 45 years
has worked
at a historically black
colleges and educator
and administrator and
one of those many black colleges
They need a little bit more fund
You've got a 20 on your job
here to send that down
to one of the black colleges
to my mom I say thank you
for everything you've done for m
and for helping countless studen
in Birmingham have the opportuni
to see a college degree
and to see an opportunity to gro
You know,
my mother's journey
may not have even begun
if not for brave journalists.
Who chose to chronicle
history in real time.
And I don't know how to ever rep
for what she's done for me
and what she's done
for so many people in Alabama.
But just know, Mama, if
if a white billionaire call
you an offer to buy your
house, please sell it
because I might want to become a
Thank you so much.
So the Correspondents Associatio
Thank you so much, Tamara Keith,
thank you all so much for not